in the first gorilla that we came across
was lying on her back she'd been shot
and she was obviously pregnant
effective ma we found that it was a
female that had been killed I like to
look at I was citizen Batman
yet the more we felt it was our own
sister who was dead was a cassette
they're not lesser get them out
and in within 15 minutes we discovered
the body of Sin Cara where these
syllabic who was the leader of this
guerrilla family he was lying on his
back with his hand over his heart with a
number of bullet wounds in his chest
[Music]
linked out of the back everybody was
stunned
these people they had lost their king
Dashawn key open and war nobody could
talk to anyone else any bets on the
public battling at the globe
they took leaves and bound the mouth and
the wounds it was almost as if these
Rangers were attempting to preserved
what remained of the spirit of the
animals then they were lifted up onto
the shoulders of men and then carried
for miles until they reached the Rangers
base
[Music]
It was as if the best of Africa the most
dignity that they could assemble in the
face of tragedy was present in this
procession
[Music]
in all six guerillas had been killed
that day the assailants unknown
[Music]
it was clear this was no ordinary
wildlife crime these animals were not
butchered for food and they weren't
killed for trophies
this was not about poaching this is
about the assassination of a family to
make a statement this was an execution